>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER TONIGHT.
THEY DO, THEY LIE REGULARLY AND
SHADE THE TROOET EVEN MORE THAN
THAT.
YOU OF COURSE NEW THAT.
IT'S OBVIOUS.
WHAT'S AMAZING IS HOW THEY DO IT
IN UNISON.
ONE WILL SAY SOMETHING FALSE,
AND WHAT SEEMS LIKE MINUTES, ALL
THE OTHERS ARE SAYING IT TOO,
THE EXACT SAME THING, SOMETIMES
WORD FOR WORD.
IT'S LIKE THEY'RE ALL TEXTING
EACH OTHER IN COMMERCIAL BREAKS.
THEY JUST KNOW INSTINCTIVELY
WHAT THE LATEST DEMOCRATIC PARTY
TALKING POINTS WOULD BE.
HERE'S THE MOST RECENT ONE .
IN THE DAYS SINCE LAST WEEK'S
ELECTIONS, ALL THE GENIUSES ON
CABLE HAVE DECIDED IT'S A
MIRAGE.
IT'S NOT REAL.
IT NEVER HAS BEEN REAL.
IT WAS ALWAYS A FAKE THREAT TO
WIN THE LAST ELECTION.
WATCH THEM SING THAT TUNE IN
PERFECT HARMONY.
>> THIS WAS NEVER AN URGENT
ISSUE.
THESE PEOPLE WERE A
THOUSAND-PLUS MILES AWAY FROM
THE BORDER.
>> TO ALSO FURTHER YOUR POINT,
IF YOU ARE SO CONCERNED ABOUT
INVADERS AND VERY BAD PEOPLE,
WOULDN'T YOU BE ON THE BORDER
TODAY INSTEAD OF YOUR SECRETARY
OF DEFENSE?
>> THEY'VE BEEN RUNNING ON AN
IMAGINARY CARAVAN.
THE PRESIDENT TALKED A LOT.
HE COULDN'T STOP TALKING ABOUT
THE SO-CALLED CARAVAN HEADING
TOWARD THE BORDER.
>> THIS STUPID [BLEEP] CARAVAN.
IT'S A LIE THAT THIS CARAVAN IS
A PROBLEM OF THAT MAGNITUDE.
>> Tucker: THIS SO-CALLED
CARAVAN, THE IMAGINARY CARAVAN.
THAT'S WHAT JEFF ZUCKER TOLD HIM
TO SAY.
TOO BAD WE NOW HAVE PICTURES.
REALITY IS THE ENEMY OF THE
PROPAGANDA.
A LARGE NUMBER OF MIGRANTS FROM
THAT CARAVAN ARE NOW JUST SOUTH
OF SAN DIEGO AND THEY'RE TRYING
TO GET INTO THIS COUNTRY.
IN THE MEANTIME, THOSE SAME
PEOPLE ARE OVERWHELMING CITY
SERVICES IN TIJUANA AND CAUSING
CRISES THERE.
THE PEOPLE ARE DOING THIS
BECAUSE THEY EXIST.
THEY'RE A PHYSICAL REALITY.
WELL, APPARENTLY, NOBODY HAS
ALERTED KAMALA HARRIS.
THAT'S WHY SHE JUST COMPARED
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
TO THE KU KLUX KLAN.
>> THE PLAN WAS THAT, WHAT WE
WOULD CALL TODAY A DOMESTIC
TERRORIST GROUP?
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE THEY TRIED TO USE
FEAR AND FORCE TO CHANGE
POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT.
>> AND WHAT WAS THE MOTIVATION
FOR THE USE OF FEAR AND FORCE?
>> IT WAS BASED ON RACE AND
ETHNICITY.
>> RIGHT.
ARE YOU AWARE OF THE PERCEPTION
OF MANY ABOUT HOW THE POWER AND
THE DISCRETION AT I.C.E. IS
BEING USED TO ENFORCE THE LAWS?
AND DO YOU SEE ANY PARALLEL?
>> I DO NOT SEE ANY PARALLEL.
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT PERCEPTION.
>> I DO NOT SEE A PARALLEL.
>> ARE YOU AWARE THAT THERE'S A
PERCEPTION?
>> TO PUT I.C.E. IN THE SAME
CATEGORY AS THE KKK.
>> Tucker: AMERICAN CITIZENS
TRYING TO PROTECT THEIR
COUNTRIES BODIERS, UP HOLDING
LAWS ARE SOMEHOW LIKE THE KKK.
IT SEEMS LIKE AN ESPECIALLY
STUPID AND VICIOUS THING TO SAY.
IT'S CRUEL, REALLY.
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL IF YOU WERE
AN I.C.E. OFFICER OR YOUR
BROTHER WAS?
CAN YOU IMAGINE THROWING OUT
THAT KIND OF SLANDER AT YOUR
FELLOW AMERICANS JUST FOR DOING
THEIR JOBS?
YOU WOULD HAVE TO BE AN AWFULLY
SELF-RIGHTEOUS PERSON TO TALK
LIKE THAT.
HARRIS IS.
SO ARE A LOT OF THEM.
LITTLE TO A MAN WHO ADVOCATES
FOR UNRESTRICTED LATE-TERM
ABORTION EXPLAIN THAT HE'S ON
JESUS' TEAM AND YOU AREN'T.
>> WHAT YOU DID FOR THOSE WHO
SEEMED LESS IMPORTANT, YOU DID
FOR ME.
NOT THE LEAST OF THESE.
IT'S JUST SOCIETY MAY ACT LIKE
THEY'RE LESS IMPORTANT, BUT WE
DON'T BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND THE
VALUE OF PEOPLE, WE UNDERSTAND
THE DIGNITY OF WORK, WE
UNDERSTAND THE VALUES THIS
COUNTRY STANDS FOR.
>> Tucker: WE UNDERSTAND THE
VALUE OF LITTLE PEOPLE, SENATOR
BROWN SAYS.
REALLY, DO YOU?
HOW ABOUT THE MILLIONS OF
AMERICAN WORKERS WHOSE WAGES
HAVEN'T RISEN IN DECADES?
AND HOW ABOUT THE PEOPLE OF
TIJUANA?
THE CARAVAN CAME NORTH BECAUSE
THEY KNEW THEY WOULD HAVE A SHOT
OF GETTING INTO THIS COUNTRY.
DEMOCRATS TOLD THEM THAT.
THEY ENCOURAGED THIS WHOLE THING
FROM THE VERY FIRST DAY.
NOW IT'S A DISASTER.
THE MAYOR OF TIJUANA SAYS HIS
CITY IS BUCKLING UNDER THE
WEIGHT OF THE MIGRANTS.
MANY ARE CRIMINALS.
DOZENS OF MIGRANTS NEVER MADE IT
TO THE BORDER.
THEY ARE STILL MISSING
PRESUMABLY KIDNAPPED BY DRUG
CARTELS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO TALK ABOUT IT.
WE INVITED CHRIS HAHN ON.
HE JOINS US TODAY.
SO, CHRIS, BEFORE WE EVEN GET TO
ALL THAT, BROWN FROM OHIO, IS
LECTURING US ON JESUS.
DO YOU THINK BROWN'S A LITTLE
BIT CLOSER TO JESUS THAN, SAY, I
AM?
>> WELL, MATTHEW 25 APPLIES
HERE, DON'T YOU THINK?
THAT'S WHAT HE WAS QUOTING.
WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO COME
TO THIS COUNTRY AND SEEK ASYLUM
LEGALLY.
AND WE ARE SENDING TROOPS TO
TEXAS WHEN THEY'RE COMING IN IN
SAN DIEGO.
IS THE PRESIDENT WATCHING RIGHT
NOW?
HE'S GOT TO MOVE THOSE TROOPS.
>> Tucker: YOU DIDN'T ADDRESS MY
QUESTION THOUGH.
IS THAT THE NEW STANDARD?
DO YOU THINK IT'S A FAIR
STANDARD?
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING I HAVE
INTRODUCED INTO THIS.
IS THAT A FAIR FORM OF POLITICAL
DISCOURSE?
>> NO, I THINK WE'RE POINTING
OUT THE HYPOCRISY ON THE RIGHT.
THEY CLAIM THEY ARE CHRISTIANS
BUT IGNORE THE TEACHINGS OF
CHRIST.
MATTHEW 25 CLEARLY DIRECTS US TO
HELP THOSE IN NEED.
>> Tucker: SO, LET ME JUST ASK
YOU, WHICH POLITICIANS WOULD YOU
SAY RIGHT NOW ON THE RIGHT ARE
INVOKING JESUS WHEN THEY TALK
ABOUT BUILDING A WALL?
WHAT EXACTLY ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT?
>> HOW ABOUT MIKE PENCE?
EVERYTHING HE DOES, EVERY TIME
MIKE PENCE TALKS HE INVOKES
CHRIST EVERY SINGLE TIME.
>> Tucker: JUST ONE EXAMPLE.
>> HOW ABOUT THE CONVENTION?
THE FIRST THING HE SAID WAS, I'M
A CHRISTIAN, A FATHER, AND A
CONSERVATIVE IN THAT ORDER.
IF HE'S REALLY A CHRISTIAN, HE
SHOULD BE PRACTICING WHAT JESUS
TAUGHT IN MATTHEW 25.
>> Tucker: AND YOU THINK THAT
JESUS WOULD HAVE OPEN BORDERS?
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING?
I'M AWARE OF THE VERSE.
>> YEAH.
>> Tucker: BUT YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH THIS IS WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING?
>> YOU'RE AWARE OF IT BUT I
DON'T KNOW THAT YOU BELIEVE IT.
THAT'S WHAT IT SAYS, TUCKER.
AND THAT'S WHAT MIKE PENCE
PRETENDS TO ACKNOWLEDGE, BUT HE
DOESN'T.
>> Tucker: I'M TRYING NOT TO END
THIS INTERVIEW RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
I'M GETTING OFFENDED.
I WONDER IF YOU UNDERSTAND THE
EXTENT YOU'RE PLAYING WITH FIRE.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S A WISE THING
TO DO?
DO YOU THINK IF MIKE PENCE GOT
UP AND SAID, "I'M FOR BUILDING A
WALL AND I'M QUOTING THIS
SCRIPTURE TO JUSTIFY IT," I KNOW
FOR A FACT THAT I WOULD SAY,
"WHOA, SETTLE DOWN.
IT'S A PUBLIC POLICY QUESTION.
IT'S A MULTI-ETHNIC,
MULTI-RELIGIOUS COUNTRY."
BUT YOU'RE SAYING THAT'S OKAY.
>> I DIDN'T MEAN TO OFFEND YOU
ON RELIGIOUS GROUND.
>> Tucker: COME ON NOW.
I'M ON JESUS' TEAM AND YOU'RE
NOT.
WHAT IS THAT?
>> I HEAR YOU.
I'M JUST POINTING OUT THAT MANY
ON THE RIGHT HAVE TAKEN CHRIST
UP AS THEIR BANNER OF HOW THEY
WANT TO GOVERN AND YET WHEN IT
COMES TO DOING SOMETHING LIKE
THIS, THEY IGNORE THE TEACHINGS
OF CHRIST.
I DO NOT THINK RELIGION OR
SCRIPTURE SHOULD BE THE BASIS IN
OUR COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: BUT IT'S OKAY WHEN
BROWN DOES IT.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
EVERYTHING'S ALLOWED NOW.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO GET WHAT WE
WANT.
IS IT OKAY TO COMPARE FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS TO THE
KKK, AS SENATOR HARRIS DID
YESTERDAY?
>> LOOK, I WATCHED THAT WHOLE
CLIP, TUCKER.
AND FRANKLY SHE WAS NOT
COMPARING THEM TO THE KKK.
SHE WAS SUGGESTING TO THE
NOMINEE THAT THERE WAS THE
PERCEPTION AMONG SOME.
SHE EVEN SAID PROBABLY
WRONGFULLY.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO CORRECT THE
PERCEPTION?
>> Tucker: I GET IT.
LOOK, A LOT OF HITLER'S CLOSEST
STAFF WORE BLUE TIES.
I'M NOT CALLING YOU A NAZI.
I JUST THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
THINK YOU ARE.
NO, SHE'S COMPARING FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS TO THE
CLAN.
AND I JUST WONDER IS THERE A
LIMIT TO WHAT YOU CAN SAY IN
PUBLIC IF YOU'RE A U.S. SENATOR
BEFORE YOU DRIVE THE COUNTRY
INTO SOME KIND OF INTERNAL
CONFLICT.
CAN YOU REALLY SAY THINGS LIKE
THAT NOW?
>> YOU SHOULD NOT COMPARE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE TO THE CLAN
AND THAT'S NOT WHAT SHE WAS
DOING.
THAT ARE THEY SHOULD FEAR I.C.E.
>> Tucker: IS THERE A POLL ON
THIS?
HOW WOULD KAMALA HARRIS, WHO'S
LIVED IN RICH PERSON WORLDS HER
ENTIRE LIFE, HOW WOULD SHE KNOW
THIS?
DOES SHE HAVE SOME POLL?
I DON'T THINK SHE DOES.
NO, SHE'S TRYING TO IMPUGN THE
PERSONAL INTEGRITY OF PEOPLE.
>> I'M SURE SHE'S TRYING TO
CORRECT THAT FEAR BECAUSE
SENATOR HARRIS IS A VERY
OSTENSIBLE PERSON.
>> Tucker: ACCUSING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS BEING LIKE THE
CLAN.
I THINK SHE'S TOTALLY
IRRESPONSIBLE.
I WANT HER TO BE RESPONSIBLE.
FINALLY, IS IT TIME TO CONCEDE
THAT THE CARAVAN IS REAL AND
THAT THEY'RE OVERWHELMING
TIJUANA.
THE MAYOR OF TIJUANA SAYS THAT A
LOT OF MEMBERS OF THE CARAVAN
ARE VIOLENT CRIMINALS AND HE'S
AFRAID OF THEM.
IS HE A RACIST, DO YOU THINK?
IT SOUNDS LIKE HE MIGHT BE.
>> NOBODY SAID IT WASN'T REAL.
THEY SAID IT WASN'T A REAL
THREAT.
>> Tucker: BUT THE MAYOR OF
TIJUANA SOUNDS LIKE A FLATOUT
RACIST, MAYBE A CLANSMAN.
DO YOU THINK HE IS?
BUT THE MAYOR OF TIJUANA SAYS
IT'S A THREAT TO HIM.
HOLD ON, WAIT.
I'M WONDERING, WOULD JESUS BE
OKAY WITH WHAT THIS MAYOR OF
TIJUANA HAS SAID?
>> IS TIJUANA ANALOGOUS TO THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA?
TIJUANA HAS A LOT LESS RESOURCES
THAN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
WE HAVE MORE PEOPLE ALONG OUR
BORDER, I WOULD IMAGINE, THAN
THERE ARE POLICE OFFICERS IN
TIJUANA.
>> Tucker: I THINK JESUS WOULD